Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
which is 2192. David P You know,
despite all of my criticisms of Joe Rogan.
Here's someone who calls in and says,
I'm not willing to criticize Joe Rogan.
Speaker 2: Hey. Did you like Rogan? I know
you hesitate to ask me about him.
Speaker 1: No, I don't. You might have me
confused with someone else. I know that there
are lots of people who won't criticize Rogan,
but I criticize Rogan all the time. In fact,
I sort of suspect he probably would never
have me back on as a result of my criticisms.
Speaker 2: You know, to an extent you'll say
things, but you still kind of go easy on him. But
he's gone, man. He's completely gone off the deep
end. You see it every single episode. I can't
even watch anymore. I can't even list anymore.
Speaker 1: I agree that he's gone
fully into right wing propaganda, but.
Speaker 2: You know, he's telling people
straight up, vote Republican. Yeah, everything.
The Democrats are bad. Blah, blah, blah.
It's just a propaganda network. It's.
It's soon enough. He'll be far right wing
commentator. He's already on his way there.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, I
criticize Rogan all the time.
I don't know what you're talking about.
The criticisms are not mealy mouthed. The
criticisms are clear and they're direct. So
I'm just not sure what you're talking about.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We're going to talk about a Texas
school board rejecting In God We Trust signs
in Arabic. Oh, boy. Here we go again. U.S.
life expectancy dropped in 2021 for the
second consecutive year. And Sean HANNITY, Tucker
Carlson and Lou Dobbs are going to be deposed in
the Dominion voting systems lawsuit against Fox
News. It is delightful, folks. It is delightful.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com and you can
use the coupon code big voting 22 to secure
a lifetime discount on your membership.